une production du studio sf
bio sans filtre le podcast on parle se
convainquent de invite les jeux pêche
quand avec moi dans mon plan on est
présentement dans l'espace l'atelier qui
étaient nos trois espaces au studio au
studio sf que vous pouvez louer donc si
vous avez un projet de podcasts audio
books web conférences séminaires
whatever vous pouvez louer nos espaces
vous avez juste à penser à votre contenu
on s'occupe de tout le reste vous
recevez votre enregistrement mix est
monté dans votre boîte courriel 48
heures après l'enregistrement
pour aller voir pardon à studio 7.0 ou
écrivez-nous aux infos un commercial
studio serpent sert pour plus de détails
bien heureux de nous écouter d'obstruer
semaine on reçoit daisy bodin qui tous
les grands lamine keïta et jonathan roy
pour un podcast à constantine gucci ont
bouffé des podcasts relaxe 11 retenez
porte quoi puis c'est souvent n'est pas
casqué plus +10 intéressant ce qui
rejoint les gens c'est vraiment une
super belle conversation est ce qu'on se
pose toujours des questions sur la vie
sur le voyage sur les drogues d'ailleurs
on en parle de manière assez cage world
soyez averti que ce sujet canada et ont
seulement c'est quoi l'amour non
seulement c'est quoi être heureux est
une bonne personne c'est quoi être
humain tu es vraiment surface mais on se
demande si on aimerait mieux pleurer
l'espace où les fonds marins la session
ces deux personnes vraiment
authentique des personnes libres des
personnes qui qui sont toujours à la
quête d'eux mêmes la quête du bonheur
c'était vraiment facilement parler que
the
way juste avant de vous laisser la
conversation va les remercie nos
commanditaires
le podcast de cette semaine et présenté
par nos amis j'ai même ce qu'est
men skate avec la nouveaux ultra premium
package qui est ici moi je vous en ai
déjà parlé c'est mais un produit pour le
soin de ma peau mes cheveux mon odeur
mes lèvres même les banques et on pas
d'esprit de ratèrent shampooing dans un
body wash d eau d où j'utilise souvent
tout avec la même odeur
un caractéristiques de mindscape cette
odeur un peu dur mais qui est incroyable
et
d'autres produits masquent d'hommes
masqués ils font tout d'abord il faut
les boxeurs les plus doux pas
confortable que les productions avec
lesquels je dors même pas besoin médical
mais leur spéciale de plus grâce peut se
le dise que tout ce qui donne un sens à
tout tout le reste c'est le labrador
revoir electric
spécialisée pour la région sa ceinture
en fait je voulais avec toi il faut
vraiment bien il voyait war cloud qui va
planer sous la douche et la technologie
skins et riffs qui fait que ça vous
empêche de tous qu'ils puisse appliquer
vos couilles
désagréable
donc ben skype dans les années on a un
code promo pour vous qui est le sans
filtre pour 20% de rabais en plus je
peins gratuit fait sauter là dessus r ce
médicament
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
en fait on avait tellement
exaltant qui complète sa crise et c'est
la chose à twitter justin matin il y
avait un rôle important voire juste un
matin on avait dit on ne sortira pas de
casse sociale avec à 10 puis à commuer
commentaires sur le podcast puis genre
il ya juste un commentaire que si tu lis
up c'est quelqu'un qui durent être car
ici complètement le team et genre comme
fuck you même
grossièrement ce genre c'était un
commentaire qui comme moi j'ai comme
je suis j'y trouvais sultan est parce qu
on parle d'une vidéo dans le podcast
quasi puis commentaires ces genres et
s'apprend comme en considération que je
programme de me faire ma propre idée
d'un sujet ou de la vidéo en question
pis ces genres dans kde écrire semaines
écrit rien sauf qu'en même temps je
devrais juste mon cas c'est ça fait 200
épisodes qu'on fait ce jeu même pas
encore capable de mac os x
10.6 aux autres qui piquent c'est parce
que ça pique ça touche une corde
sensible ou c'est juste au final toutes
les commentaires ghost comment tu parce
que ce qui est qu'avec juste dire
maintenant
sru la coupe de cheveux à ph et
n'importe quoi
mais là la vérité si je trouve qu'il
aimait tant un un commentaire quelqu'un
qui me dit maintenant tu es là doit
chier ça me dérange beaucoup mais ce qui
me dérange c'est quand c'est qu'un un
commentaire est écrit pi se veut
intelligente mais temps mais qui est
rempli de fausses rhétorique pi2 de
raisonnement mardi et on le sait où est
ce que le jeu lille comment tant pis
dans ma tête je pourrais raincy ce qui
est écrit leur pendant cinq minutes et
c'est comme ça qui me portent le plus
parce que je veux pas non plus prendre
le temps
commence en
mai par rapport à toi non non sauf que
c'est comme si un sultan avoir envers
moi et envers notre
ego ses quais on c'était quelqu'un qui
avait une opinion c'est quelque chose
trouver bonne la personne dit ces
personnes-là
de la marge brute à nana plaisir comme
nous on est capable d'être judo comme si
l'opinion est valide doucier la mare
mettons dans le top 6 essais mais bref
mais ces cinq semaines c'est
mais par exemple dans que d'être
défensifs podcast jeu s'appellera arrivé
de dire des choses que toi même après
mais en même temps faut je suis
l'acceptent parce que souvent quand on a
détruit
en 2006 il ya beaucoup de la vérité qui
sera aussi puis des voies la vérité nous
des fois on va dire de quoi qu'on pense
vraiment mais quel est le fil des
parties malheureusement pilot ben on
était là on a dû la faire le faux
vis-à-vis mois ou jusqu'à prendre des
trucs à la légende aussi le souvent dû
déjà fort puis après ça s'est pris trop
pour du cash qui comprend dix mille fois
donc comme tu gagnes dans nos
discussions en fin de soirée le défend
fait juste du n'importe quoi pour passe
à autre chose puis on est capable de
juste dire n'importe quoi en sachant que
c'est n'importe quoi ou 8 mètres carrés
enregistré le monde peuvent prendre
vraiment
quelque chose puis demain pu être
d'accord ce que j'ai
physique
afin d'avoir des discussions parce que
je dis juste je sais puisque je pense
défaut
jarron pas le gisement pour un petit
cadeau d'apporter un point et plus je me
dis bon honnêtement j'ai pu d'opinion je
suppose que je pense parce que torresin
gérait du titre comme rendu justice aux
jeunes c'est limogés mais je trouve ça
l'fun quand tu es rendu le pas ce que ça
veut dire que tu étais en train de
vraiment penser à what do you want
qu'est-ce qu'est ce que je crois
vraiment si c'est vraiment ça je ne sais
plus c'est l'fun parce que la tête en
reine vraiment écouté les deux côtés de
la médaille oui meilleur et fatah propre
opinion sur quelque chose et je trouve
ça l'fun mais il ya un milieu où est-ce
qui étoffent nordiques ont patiné on
parle sans rien de concret mais genre il
est minuit qui étoffent parce que tu
sais plus son opinion et août
combrailles comme de sa part l'humilité
pour admettre c'est aussi le bois c'est
quoi ton opinion puis on en parlait
justement hiver avec adib encore une
fois ou est ce qu'on disait t'es lui
parlait du fait que pour lui c'était
vraiment difficile de laisser aller le
désir d'avoir raison au challenge est
aussi pour moi comme de d'accepter que
quand même ne pas avoir raison et qui
vient puis après ça c'est que d'accepter
ce s'étoffe le tir avant que je t'ai
connu
je croyais qu'ils étaient une personne
qui faisait juste s'écouter ou qui est
mon exact qu'ils voulaient me ton avoir
tout le temps raison finalement
j'ai vraiment où va plus que je pensais
à tout plein de pas tant que ça en fait
ce que j'ai réalisé de lui c'est qu'il
voulait apprendre sur plein de choses ça
c'est une fan normalement les gens sont
tellement fermé qu'ils veulent pour
s'ouvrir à d'autres possibilités tout
c'est comme un plus c'est quoi ta nature
mais tesla déconstruire
d'où tu viens comment qui naturellement
a commenté tpiy comment tu voudrais à
cesser le travail
mais d'admettre sa d'admettre que puis à
au delà d'admettre de pas avoir raison
d'admettre de pas savoir mais c'est une
des choses dans mon choix d'avoir raison
c'est la sphère la plus angoissante et
de dire j'ai raison
ce qu'on voit c'est moi je trouve ça
plus difficile d'affirmer j'ai raison
qu'il a fuie gpo raison ces genres si ce
gain vous pouvez me faire confiance j'ai
raison je connais je trouve ça bien plus
angoissante parce que parce que c'est
parce que tu tenais de la pression quand
10 août mais la pression de devoir avoir
raison - cc j'ai raison ouais si que ces
gros budget reste certes en contient un
volet quand je pense qu'ils arriveraient
à matin
mais je trouve ça carrément
dingue et moi pour toi même quand tu es
jeune tu prends la décision des bonbons
à ça pour ça c'est bon écoute et va
s'arrêter mais à la fin de la journée tu
vas quand même à l'hiver parce que peut
payer ça aussi c'est juste que j'ai
jamais l'impression de choix faire des
choix dans vie je fais juste faire des
affrontements
j'existe y à tokyo dimanche tout comme
le vin ça des fois c'est aux
communes et quatre autres personnes
qu'est-ce que tu penses pu passer par la
tête
on s'envoie l'homme commence a dit 'on
moi je viens de revenir de voyage il ya
un souvenir de voyage dans l'eau chaude
justin bieber que j'ai pas encore vu
deux jours j'ai pas encore vu péage est
pas encore vu donc fait qu'est
vraiment un beau voyage non mais c'est
vrai ce que tu dis de partir avec
quelqu'un la première fois
c'était prend vraiment cana de noël est
dans sa bulle tout le temps ces
nouvelles relations mais quoi de cammas
avant cette nacelle
tout était tout au plus moi j'ai jamais
voyagé backpack c'est comme mon premier
voyage qui est
absolument ouija la première fois que je
voyais autorités de
dubaï ont passé les douanes à pied petit
on n'avait rien de gérer à da vinci
tester aussi entendre que vite fait que
c'est plus compliqué un peu infections
dans les plus tapés sénat pour bander
affaire mais non
moins qu'avec quelqu'un comme moi avec
lily c'est un peu ça je me sens
tellement bien comme protégée parce que
je suis quelqu'un qui l'avait déjà fait
avec ça c'est le fun ne juge pas celui
des connaissez salut dans le fond un
petit enfant est déjà léonie qu'à un peu
de piment à la même place effective
connaissais déjà un peu les spots mais
il ya un peu aussi comme moi est il
vraiment dans sa bulle puis j'aurai
pendant sa taille les pieds pas type
organisé mi pour organiser puis
comme étant des parties 20 jours ah oui
quand même s'est passé l'an non mais
c'est quand vous étiez en plus j'étais
vraiment bien voyages randonnées jeunes
et j'ai dit aux gars que je suis bien en
voyage mais honnêtement je m'ennuie le
jardin - puits mauger bon
monsieur joaquín sa
botte je pourrais rester le designer
mais brest a beau voyage je pensais
vraiment bien entendu ça le confirmer
des propos que j'avais besoin de
confirmer des enfants d'une relation
métier
de top
10 et 20 jours et qu'une personne dans
un environnement qui connaît pas
vraiment assez déstabilisant si tu peux
voir la vraie personne si
c'est à des prêts situation est ici plus
fort qu'elle a peut pas contrôler ses
réactions vraiment connu aucun
rachat qui a mis de plus en fait du
voyage c'est une maîtrise en droit que
tu allais tu la dernière place y avait
comme une petite place de sauvetage
italie et la polio je sais pas si vous
vous êtes déjà allé c'est un endroit
vraiment pas touristique c'est une
grande plage a dit le co qui commence à
avoir un peu de touristes j'ai adoré si
on habitait sodec type hutsebaut la
plage pas d'épicerie il n'y a pas de
panneaux
c'est un monsieur qui pensaient que son
camion le matin et xi fruits et légumes
s'est foutu de bonnes pour pouvoir
manger on a juste manger des bananes des
tomates
on se levait le matin on se faisait béni
bronze et on faisait rien on lisait il
ya des chiens des chats
si vous avez vos salles et ça change
tout le monde subit la change toi moi ça
m'a manqué grands demain soir de sa
poule mais te souhaite un but si tu
serais plus de ce qu'ils ont fait comme
ça toi demain non non ne sortait pas par
tout mal manger marshall et fort couru
beaucoup dehors sauf que
je
sais que ça paraît pas foule qui suivait
son éclatement
secours attendent centre-ville
apparemment non genre sur le bord du
fleuve à quai au moins - peu de nature
oui mais non mais pourrait vivre à
montréal
l'éleveur sans soleil s'étoffe à
120 jours c'est assez pour que tu
décroches source pas jeu des particules
et
ouais trompe pas c'est trop moment
danois non non non on ans passés en deux
matches pourrait je pourrais tu pourrais
vivre ailleurs quand même moi je
pourrais moi je préfère ça que
j'ai commencé à bas californie faire un
peu de surf à ces rites hausse
le soft est immense puis moi je suis
vraiment nul en soins fiqcs tester
rock'n roll qui s'est dit cependant
pas en rester là coop de joie parce que
si on est allé faire du drive à cabo
pulmo qui est une place renommée pour la
dette avec des
vrais mans vraiment jolie comme place et
après ça on ne priment petit avion pour
toulouse je crois on a fait un petit
bout tatum
cozumel cause michael youn fameuse
accident alors c'est la poisse on a
récité dans ce coin là pour un bon
bouton a fini par aller à maroilles qui
dans le monde dans le fond le seul coin
de belize
mexique et une place vraiment un vrai
manque ou des
faits et que le mexique en général près
de dangereux mais je trouve que tu
respectes les gens puis type en train de
vendre la drogue toute banale moi on est
mal puis je devrais pas vote est une
jeune fille vote à la seule quête par
quelques pas de touristes que ça va être
drôle
j'aurais voyage est un ensemble mais
finalement c'est magnifique le mexique
c'est pas si idiot chicago
mémorial et à sa mort et qui cependant
je passe partout dans le monde sont en
effet attendus c'est ce qu'il perçoit
dans les grosses bécanes mexico - luiz
paulo que city one akirov
ya plein d'autres villes mexicaines qui
sont c'est elle et je pense les dix
places les plus dangereux sa planète
dans top 10 mais tant il ya comme lui
deux places mais quand même j'exagère
peut-être 5 mai mais y en a pas mal mais
mais mais je trouve que les gens sont
sympathiques
ils veulent tout tenté et des puis ça
coûte pas cher aussi ça c'est ce que
j'aime du mexique ces sources est en
train de tourner évidemment sur le coup
témoins tulum cozumel puis pas de carmen
toute sa place au géant du christ
marcheurs mais
messi bolatti l'océan est magnifique aux
jumelles c'est une place extraordinaire
le darfour est les poissons lit des gros
cliff mène des chorales n 5 se leva qui
nous écoutent qui ont pas au kindle est
apparu un accident jeu qu'on parle de ça
parce que c'est quand même parce que
nous on s'est parlé proche du nouvel an
au tf 1 oui parce que ça serait arrivé
il y avait de la chute m'arrivait aussi
pourquoi je filais pam ont acheté à
appeler point là pour mieux les
mêmes et s'écoute s'est passé pour ceux
qui nous écoutent qui savent pas
histoire mais voilà ces courants exact
chemin des rêves alex ça s'appelle cathy
jordan c'est un cri zabal live
puis jetée à peu près à 130 pi et
de la fin du monde avec je remonte
tranquillement jeumont femmes ont fui
mend tape mon stop de décompression et
seul bord du cliff sera soit d'abord ce
genre de job daf qu'il ya beaucoup de
courant on laisse aller les spots
d'installer cette barre d'humour mais
souvent tu as dit hop au breuil faki ça
pousse vers le haut il y en a même qui
peut cette série par le blues comme
ça arrive rarement mais pour moi ce
distance et ariza journée loeb du talent
c'est dangereux par foucault tourments
de trouver exact fait chez moi je tends
drainera l'axé à vingt pieds des
compresseurs à des quotas
puis j'ai été poussé vers le haut de 20
à 10 facal quick et j'ai ainsi de tout
enlever mon âge et mon manque
d'expérience en six mois j'ai peut-être
150 d'ailleurs max puis mon manque
d'expérience fait que j'y peux rien j'ai
assez vite pour
string gobain et j'ai peut-être même
retenu mon souffle un peu en même temps
puis la petite vache à lait juste pas
pipi salam en salle les libellules à
mons dans mon sens et ça a fait que dans
le fond
j'ai paralysie complète
ehr monte foods a fini par remonter en
haut j'aime on a fait quand c'est arrivé
je monte je me suis dit je vois
redescendre tout le monde m'a dit comme
si tu montes trouver tout à leur dessert
refaite en trois minutes tout un petit
peu plus longtemps pour être sûr de
décompresser et c'est ce que j'ai fait
quand je remonter à la surface encore le
j'ai réalisé que je perdais
tranquillement
la mobilité de ma main droite après ça
c'était marge en droit après ça c'était
tout mon bureau parce que c'était toute
ma gens après ça c'était tout le côté
droit de mon cerveau qui me fonctionnait
pas et faites le moi j'étais là tout le
monde parlait tout comme biais de jeux
réalisé que j'avais de la misère à
parler que je regarde ma madame astruc
j'exécute john doonan annick bas à
cannes at mouvement
fasse pas trop ma barque seul bateau on
à paris non moi je regardais la
l'échelle je regarde la plante capable
après
c'est zéro proche des tripes d'ayo
escale en
examen c'est son nom tu sais que ça va
revenir ce qui arrive est maintenant des
tripes de mouchoirs a vu ses soins ceux
aussi qui arrivent ce que tu penses de
tellement pas de pansements reste une
même été solide mais cette lettre c'est
sûr je regarde la la la la la la banque
pas capable la poignée fait le
finalement mais juge avait pas deux
comme par deux connaissances dans l'eau
puis aussi ce qui arrive souvent c'est
que les gens le
ya des gens qui sont plus capable de
respirer
doit être vraiment vraiment dangereux
c'est le pyjama finalement ils
réussissent à mener dans le bateau fait
qu'il sort il dispose et
fisheye même j'ai jamais vu pareil
pour être analysés
ce qui ce qui me paraît places de cada
à siffler ce qu'est ce que je ressens
infectés comme paralysés mais tu es
conscient de ce qui ce passe droit mais
tu peux pas trop me dire que j'allais
l'extérieur ce n'est pas lille était sur
le bateau tu me disais ouais mais à
l'extérieur c'est quand la moitié de ton
visage
mais lily allen allemand était solide et
à l'urca mattia me flattez à ces deux
hommes donnent
de l'argent pour spéculer le sable ou à
l'armée je pense que ça parlera pas je
pensais vraiment à des connexions qui
qui qui qui sont pauvres ils m'ont donné
de l'oxygène
après ça je tu arrivé à
capitale
après deux heures et demie teinte rose
art marche j'étais capable de bouger mes
services tout coup le titre du genre
s'il était en panique dans
le corps humain manier fait fort tarnac
puis
il quand que tu as un moment de panique
souvent on va il ya notre instinct qui
embarque son instinct de survie qui
embarque je sais pas ce que la mienne
est hyper calme du et super cammas pause
puis à lasser de comprendre et
d'analyser tout ce qui suppose avant de
créer une panique générale
fake je les vis tu sais très très très
intense mais mais j'ai gardé contrôler
tout le long même durant les 12 heures
de décompression d'engendrer dessus un
don d'un milliard d'euros 12 heures de
temps avec une petite madame qui est
avec moi j'avais
la
démission
comme simuler une décompression way
exact thomas sargent même mettons là que
tu prends de l'oxygène pour deux heures
après 20 minutes enfin presque trois
heures une dernière enfin presque 4 à
c'est tellement rare pu masquer fait mal
puis dans l'attenté d'un petit affaires
pitot regarder netflix je pars avec la
petite madame be s'est bien passé je
t'aime tellement roulé dans vie mais ça
j'allais tuer j'allais correct jetons
encore dit encore des petits-enfants
séquelles un petit peu
cherche mes mots un peu plus que normal
mais de mieux en mieux j'ai eu un
insolite pts 10 moi je
n avais déjà eu dans le passé
mais jamais aussi autant intenses que
ceux que j'ai eus nature de me réveiller
dans nuit puis je revivais l'événement
avoir servi 4 5 fois facile et même
durant la journée - jali grosses crises
de panique au point où que j'aille
l'ipcc est faux faux faux appelé
l'hôpital en blues qui foutaient arrête
alors qu'ils étaient retournés dans
l'eau
absolument
je sais ce que tu vaux t'il le code le
docteur m'a dit voici le trois semaines
at-on une date marque puis c'est quoi le
19 fisc physiquement je peux y aller
dans l'eau parce que physiquement tu as
du devoir attendre ou absents grosse
tomate à trois semaines neuf trois
semaines neuf puis à passer vos acteurs
fassent des tests tout va bien puis
c'était sont bons mais le tout paris
dans l'eau puis je suis différent me
theiss la journée que j'étais correct
puis
j'ai dû au stress à castries
la première fois c'est un charlot des
super bien été et
le y avait pas de paliers de
décompression fait le plus mal au
drame ce qui était celle de concession
avec quand je retournais après je m'en
vais faire mon je pense la 2e div 2 and
isles horrifique
jetant tannique crises d'anxiété mais
j'ai mon affaire piste et russell puis
en plus ces chefs mettons tout le cas
des crises d'anxiété savard est posée
par an est monté dans le site et le
personnel mais non c'est bien ce que ça
peut paraître un peu pareil d'absolument
limite
ça va peut-être sortir un activité se
fait ressentir en plaine a aussi amené
l'anxiété vos sorties site soit faire
des gaffes votre bégaye tout
mais
mais où je plus les fois de démontrer ce
que je t'ai lost me le disait après puis
je capable d'être contre j'ai vécu des
chutes dans ma vie j'ai fait des traités
comme les tripes de mort centre de la sq
qui m'ont honnêtement vraiment aidé que
mon anxiété vraiment beaucoup
puis
c'est ça mon après 5 drive total je te
re devenu quand même assez normal en
dessous de l'eau j'ai encore une touche
beaucoup plus
de sa pension oui mais c'est semapa
c'est ma deuxième troisième passion du
roi klein qui drive pis
j'avais tellement par des puits capable
d'en du loup le pipi pour voir cet
univers bonne voie c'était le monde qui
complètement fou le site et n'a jamais
fait de jeu qu'il faut que tu le sais
que
j'ai jamais fait de plonger avec ac agir
maintenant mais je voudrais je fais avec
un tube au loin
le long temps il y avait tellement de
poisson il ya un spot on était parti de
doucement dans voyages à taïwan qui ont
fait et qui pas loin de six spots de
plongée son valet le sait vraiment où on
arrive le champagne ou du burundi parle
arrive en dessus du lot c'est comme ça
[Rires]
on est resté rien alors
dépassé c'est comme si c'était un autre
monde peut tout observer les affaires le
terrain plus comme justement quand tu es
sur le manche n'a basculé
la poste on doit plus y affluent
la vie est tellement belle lula s'est
vraiment magique skull c'est incroyable
pari qu'on a découvert plus ce que à
l'extérieur de la planète quand
une sainte
reviennent le camp ne sait pas ce
qu'elle l'extérieur est tellement
fascinant ont choqué plus facilement
qu'elle veut que l'un deux mois ben je
sais pas l'eau l'intérieur tu comprends
pas tout le temps mais je pense avoir
tout le temps être le mieux l'effet
passe comme s'ils faisaient partie de
nous c'est mon avis l
extérieur comme ces va découvrir
je vais attendre quoi qui est quand même
vraiment le réseau terrer dans cela mais
je trouve que ça m'en dit quand même sur
ton caractère oui mais plus intéressés à
l'autre qu'à moi on dirait mes
maîtresses en plus basse avant qu'on est
une bulle qui une belle love and rush
dans les flops
c'est vraiment la thèse ces fous pareils
tous ses deux enfants qu'on
sait aussi maintenant c'est l'espace
l'infini malgré
ses infinies ce qu'on peut découvrir
petit ce qui le met dans l'autre sens où
si tu leur font plus dessus rapetisse
l'infiniment petit entraînement petit
mais
ça aussi c'est comme se parle à lui fini
la balle est maintenant acquis quelle
pression parce que tel attendant balaton
milieu des tombes maintenant c'est comme
qui sera fait on est de s'ouvrir je m'en
excuse mais c'est comme si si c'est
comme méthode qui divise par deux tout
le temps au temps le temps constructif
et par deux cas et c'est ce qu'on va
tout le temps découvrir les enfants
c'est souvent un facteur en physique
qu'on avait vu que je suis mariée ça
m'avait ça va exploser ma taille qu'on
avait vu que genre tout les toute la
matière afin que maintenant la table il
ya des espaces entre les oreilles
des gens
[Musique]
pourraient penser ben ouais c'est clair
mais je pense que on en fait on comprend
pour intégrer le mot infinite space
ouais je pense qu'on le comprend pas
c'est trop grasse et trop peu pour
savoir ça fait juste part si c'est
dommage qu'on le comprend pas comme il
faut parce que chris je pense que la
plage on serait vraiment une plus belle
espèce parce qu'on était honni focus
offert de l'argent du faso près du shit
en interne mais la réalité c'est qu'on
est une petite espère numéro deux de
l'énergie
en éjectant des cas justement c'est des
astronautes relais qui vance dans
l'espace puis 10-4 dans l'espace se
réalisera main que dans l'avenir on
n'est pas différente culture
différemment et différentes frontières
on est une équipe sur un match et
ploemeur même vaisseau ne flattent
ensemble il faudrait que tout le monde
nous recevoir de haut pour réaliser
qu'on est juste une arche comme cette
débile que qui volent n'affrontaient
cela il veut farce jeudi lendemain ce
qu'il veut je pense que mes soucis mais
ça va être c'est qu'on peut aller la
burqa parce que vous faites
c'est là que je serais
moi maintenant je pourrais aller le 20
mai lieux sous les mers ça me dérange
l'épaule mais aller dans le vide en eau
le ca murray paniqué au pitch est
pourquoi ouais je sais pas pourquoi on
dirait que c'était des gamins on dirait
que c'est sais je sais maintenant que
c'est un excellent infini qui mène à
aucun contrôle fait le plus peur non non
même pas mais maintenant la mer je sais
que ça a une fin même si on le paye qui
dresse sur rennes avant la fin je sais
pas mais on dirait que l'idée doit être
dans quelque chose puisqu'elle s'y met
on en est on par contact avec la gravité
ou avec note orbite on s'envoie cpo a
défini le même si je sais les gens
mourir avant d'être à dupuy même si dans
l'eau je veux mourir avant d'arriver au
bout tu le voudrais qu'il y des deux
comme quelque chose qui finit pas me
créer une anxiété le massif mois les
fonds marins mais tu plaisantes et same
plus hostiles comme
environnementaux faudrait que tu es pris
je les ai connus aussi
qu'en fin mais imagine parce que imagine
semer mais dans l'espace décrue des prix
oscillant troisième
[Rires]
temps relève thomas
oui c'est quoi ces moyens là c'est sûr
je suis opposé - j'ai reçu à 30 ou mais
maitient je me dis comprendre les
concepts de jeu cette panique
at elle
ajouté dans les spots anneaux et
moi je vais vraiment ce que
[Rires]
j'ai vu
il y avait comme plein de plantes c'est
jean valjean avec des animaux
gb je croyais semaine que la russie
avait une station de base qui a ramené
un animaux mal de chaque
espace pour s'assurer que j'y crois un
coach ici mais au moins il ya de quoi tu
peux aller s'installer sur mars ou sade
mais moi je ne sais pas je voyais tout
plein de verdure comment est ce que tu
veux dire mais je pense que c'est une
image d'un film parce que je le
comprends je la vois ce que laisse à ses
films sa part le pied des plantes
partout mais c'est dans l'axé sur ces
images de films si son talent est
co-organisé je sais pas trouvé avec matt
damon de marché ces nombreux jamais avec
les élites sont un groupe in&fi
compagnie si non le film avec avec
l'épaule c'est bon c'est bon comme
interstellaire ces gens dans les mers
non
croyants ces trois dj mais ça me fascine
collective longtemps
pilule des prix gp
mais au contraire paquet positivement
desjardins qui sauront piquer jeudi
alors sur le bout de match j'arrive plus
à petit pour le moche en écoutant sur la
loi spéciale ce que j'avais à porte
noire
je pousse se fait sous mes jambes
j'étais comme vraiment plus émotif que
owen sujet mon ampoule tacle au mugello
je passe une expérience en termes de
ville c'est quoi c'est que maintenant
c'est quoi qui traditionnels
baptêmes et on
maintient la faim qui le
metical par retrouve sa fille la fin le
pire c'est que
c'est tellement fait pour genre que ça
soit comme et l'autre à
matthew dubé toute piste -comme sorgen
vous m'avez eu
jamais leur
[Rires]
talent et hydrique mais oui mais je ne
serai monia soir j'ai lâché
cérémonie asseoir pour la femme donne
mitcham qui ont fait ces cinq jours de
petites cérémonies pis
enfin alpha est un trip de moche mais on
le fait d'une façon
non partie fait gaffe on s'installe on
se met des genres de blind foule puis on
écoute de la musique qui ont frôlé à
l'intérieur c'est vraiment plus interne
que rire avec toi j'ai un bon
travail sur because tu votes des guides
sont des hommes en fait notre vie où
allez vous poser à faya des affaires
qu'on met d'ailleurs pis c'est aussi des
façons jamais le petit oubliée puis
quand il fait un truc comme ça souvent
savoir sortir un mini tfc puis de ça ça
ça fait maintenant un peu plus rythme
avoir des moments de
deux parties petite vie tout plein
d'émotions mais à la fin quand tu t'en
sors de ce genre d'aventuré de jon
9,4 à la fin tu étais tellement ils sont
rapides et be back
on devrait que sept mois ça ça me ramène
à mon vrai
j'en ai fait
un ou 2 1 ou 2 1 2 1 un petit match à
maroilles
qui était magnifique on a fait
on a fait un genre de ses temps forts
street nous disent qu'on a fermé un gang
qui avait tenu sur une plage puis on a
juste relaxé on a fait de manger moi je
coupais déco connaître le long jeu
là foxy sur un à façade vient tenter
quand tu prends du moche mais peu
importe les focus sur une tâche c'est
comme si c'est la plus belle chose que
lotus racing qui comprend pas son titre
chacun ses enfants des comics la nature
sa navette incroyable to be noix de coco
qui donne de l'eau
bue en plus haut gâteau à l'origine je
suis les guette
jardin d'éden non mais c'est vrai mais
le retour à la région de péché originel
ne me dicte encore s'asseoir parce que
sa tante pas dépendance de mono
les besoins de jeu si oui dimanche
à la piscine
absolument mais je suis battu mais tant
que tu dis est une série de même est ce
que tu vas avec un
[Musique]
bac l'intention de dire que je veux sur
j'aime bien que je pense je travaille
là-dessus exactes sur antarès exact
formé faut que je suis vraiment suis
quand même battu pendant bonnes affaires
des fois j'en ai fait d'être un bouc et
aucune des scans la salle et puis c'est
ce qu'ils peuvent
se concentre sur ce pourait une
arabesque valais serait une autre chose
pendant 12 heures parce que c'est ça
c'est ça et kings of war ghost
of titans fasse pas mal de matches pour
te rendre le parce que - temps chaque
fois j'en ai fait c'était comme juste je
me sentais bien j'avais du fon pige à
moudre ci dessus et maintenant tu prends
2 et 5 grammes
jeu tu peux aller loin va pousser ça dit
pas je sais pas qu'est ce que tu as pris
je sais pas exactement la quantité mais
tu peux avoir un trip d'iowa ce cas avec
des mecs le match allait vraiment
mais deux semaines mais c est aussi
parce que là on le voit comme de la
drogue mais en vérité c'est une plante -
et ça pose la
finale
pour coûter il y en a plein d'autres
plans qui sont des thés ou à des trucs
qui sont très les jets mais ça on a
décidé que ce thème drugs and rock comme
il ya un système méchas illégal puis en
fait on prend des pilules d'aider des
compagnies forme il concept de
l'événement de la marque sur le corps à
long terme mais c'est en train de sortir
on le voit le monde la kétamine le
manche d'ailleurs est ce que c'est si
des outils d'aidé médecine qui ça fait
tellement longtemps que ça existe puis
ça va devenir de new wave traiter la
dépression traiter l'anxiété traiter 10
pts 10 on sait que ça s'en vient il va
avoir des cendres en cours d'année je
veux quand je veux d'abord un mot c'est
moi ça me drame aidé dans ma vie puis je
sais que ça les débats du monde me dit
que je connais qui je trouve que c'est
vraiment mieux ce que prendre des
antidépresseurs prendre là la marque qui
qui est donnée pour enlèvement faire de
l'argent plus que d'autre chose puisque
fait du bien c'est sûr que you on en a
parlé avec bernard
fait n'en ait pas de casse sur un
livescore justement je pense que je t'en
avais parlé le jeu libre
injecter les deux
pieds levés ce qu'ils disent c'est que
les études sur sont vraiment été stoppés
ou
est ce que une des raisons pour
lesquelles s'étaient justement à cause
du fait qu' il y avait un ange et
monétaires liées aux médicaments autres
le pis que ce n'était pas nécessairement
quelque chose qui est que les compagnies
pharmaceutiques voulait développer
la connaissance mettons que là ça
revenait tranquillement puis mais je
suis d'accord que possiblement que luce
qui parlait de la thérapie assistée je
pense que ça c'est parce que le gros
problème de ces affaires le sais tu mets
ton l'iowa ce qu'elle dit on en parlait
avec les game watch qui a tout à fait
ouvrir à faire un truc bien à ce que met
pas dans un contexte où est ce que tu es
forking au fin fond d'une jungle à à des
kilomètres de l'hôpital la plus proche
où est-ce qu'ils s'y habituent faire
même si cause du fait du switch mouton
le team si je comprends toi mais tu as
peur été bâtie autour de six arrivées de
trois cas de trop mauvais côté millions
de personnes qui en ont pris comment tu
perds tu auriez parce que ça c'est sûr
qu'il ya déjà des problèmes des
problématiques qui arrive qui sont plus
graves que ceux laissés sur puis c'est
sûr que c'est sûr que d'aider des
personnes qui ont des sensibilités
psychologique qui devrait pas faire ce
qu'ils en font parce qu' aucun suivi
puis quelqu'un sa part dans l'autre sens
ils peuvent pas se faire aider parce que
personne qualifiée pour les aider à mort
un chaman qui se proclament chaman fond
d'un trou tu sais moi mettons le siav un
centre ici vu ou est ce que tu vaux la
pisse et des professionnels qui
représentent d'ailleurs wes cavale
d'abîmer sais pas si c'est pas dans un
contexte comme alternatifs en car même
la médecine alternative mais si c'était
vraiment comme des gens qui ont des
formations pour pouvoir sortir de
dissocier des problèmes de pouvoir d
infusion de ramener rapidement à toi
sochaux d'armé mais je juge juste à dire
par exemple tu mets ton de montrer deux
coups même montré blaska mettons le
chaman les chamans qui sont des fois
sont six chats manoir pour aider des
gens son il y en a qui sont vraiment
bons mais c'est quand même loin de la
belle de
mai je sais pas c'est quoi que la
médecine
mauvais temps il faut juste fait guider
pour te faire ramener mais que
physiquement
parce que rapidement multiples loin
d'être un expert de ça mais maintenant
ça commence quand même soit vraiment un
bad trip complet le probablement qu'on
peut s'endormir puis-je attira place
d'aller scrappé des affaires rapide
vraiment tiré commencé à tomber au petit
pas vraiment ce cap aider à passer ce
jeudi non mais ton petit roman psychose
le tout commence à avoir des effets qui
sont parce que c'est vrai tu as raison
il y en a qui fonctionne madame liliane
madame j'ai vu qu'un documentaire a fait
sonner fixe qui je me rappelle c'est
quoi non mais c'est vraiment bien fait
ça montre les bons côtés prime avec
piquionne madame qu'elle était plus
capable à vous la voulez pas respirer à
penser que tente une louche pas quoi
pour lafarge les ja c'est d'ouvrir sa
bouche plesita paca baby tu as raison
mais écoute absolument raison je trouve
qu'il devrait les chamans devra être là
puis en arrière devrait tout envoie
quelqu'un met dix quelqu'un de au moins
prendre soin
ccc ce faux qu'il faut que ça soit mieux
que ce soit mieux entourer les enfants
c'est que moi je pense qu'il faut que ce
soit décriminaliser oui puis par le fait
même sort et demi en touriste mais
encore les gens ont faim dans des pays
où est-ce que c'est pas tic en vente ici
un peu tout croche et pas comme ici les
ja on va là on vole la buse 1 c'est ça
qui est dommage on vraiment la buse et
comme si ce parce que les gens ne savent
pas comment faire non plus et comme
comme le plus bel exemple c'est le pote
un ok on sait pas quand ma famille on en
fait un peu trop plein les gens tristes
comme l'alcool c'est beaucoup plus
simple parce qu'on des concombres à saas
fee plus en tant que ça fait partie nous
notre vie mais le pote lors tout à fait
mais bachelot c'est peut-être comme si
tu avais bu une bouteille de vin tout
seul
puis surtout le matin la scop il même
machault mendy sur very very far pointe
fac ça le besoin de
d'une certaine
en fait un an d'ici là un encadrement
kiki bonne mais aussi de poser de france
est nécessairement vous centrez vu le
cas des chances
il faut être brillant et retraite le
team moi je verrais mettons dans un
monde futur le genre d'estérel with war
cloud est ce que tu es belle aux
charlatans est heureux mais genre place
d'assistant with you est voleur qui
apprennent à faire pour t'aider dans ton
jeu dans le sens plein de bruch qui vont
stimuler dans ton trip qui vont y avait
dans un domaine sécuritaire dans une
armoire je pense je vois aucun point
négatif à se dire s'il ya plein de
tels arguments aussi de dire tu
m'étonnes qu'ils vont fermer
pharmaceutique leur but ce n'est pas de
l'argent
si c'est vrai
c'est vrai parce que n'importe quelle
compagnie voilà je faire de l'argent
mais
legault qui propriétaire de sa retraite
d'aller voir ce que proment qui veut
faire l'argent aussi il y avait donc les
cas je vote je vois tard là c'est 35 ans
qui se mouille pas ce que ça rapport
avec ce que tu viens juste de dire oui
tu as raison que mon faire de l'argent
mais c'est parce que y'a vraiment les
alternatives comme bien manger à base de
données les prélats quelqu'un croit
juste juste de changer ce que la
personne mange et la personne dort bien
je suis à vous jeter une douche
on est les premiers à on en parle je
pense à toutes les pages 4 et qu'on en
parle les élus sont déjà promouvoir les
bonnes habitudes de vie bien manger
faire du sport bien nommé gérer son
stress à la méditation enfanter c'est
des choses qu'on répète qu'on répète
qu'on répète comme amel stationnant
papote
mettons les éditions laffont gérer son
stress du point par magna
on n'a pas tout le temps et puis si les
choses que tu peux faire devant le plus
d'impact sur la santé plombier mais
après ce
jeu pendant un certain aussi que en
privé à des pressions pour du monde sont
vraiment dans le besoin
ça va sauver des vies c'est sûr après ce
est ce qu'il ya un danger peut-être que
certaines personnes vont pour devenir
vont vont utiliser ce comme unique
solution plutôt que d'utiliser une
panoplie combiné panoplie de solutions
ou s'est en sorti oui peut-être que tu
es là juste là dessus prenant des
risques
mais après ce
que je les ai par rapport au
thème étant le le balado qu'on a fait
avec lui quand même très critique par
rapport à la vie finalement plus on n'en
parlait plus j'étais comme acquis mais
c'est pas mal plus critique par rapport
à tout ce qui entoure cette industrie
l'unité plus que la drogue en tant que
tel ce que tu es oui la drogue en tant
que tel il ya des res par edu peut
justement faire abattre et par un petit
costume mais en général comme tout comme
très rock et des risques à toutes les
autres
risques à faire du vélo littéralement
tout les médicaments il apprécie c'est
comme si je pense quand même que on
idéalise
certaines drogues ou certaines pratiques
parce que on pense qu'ils sont naturels
ou ancestrales ou telle qu il se fait
partie de la tradition de ce pilot pitt
et dans le balade aussi dit quelque
chose qui exploite aussi c'est comme on
est sympa l'histoire l'historique de
cette drogue leur rends compte que c'est
pau va pas des millénaires
c'est pourtant dans la culture de ces
pays le comme on est content
parce qu'on romantisme espèce de retour
justement à
ces séances extra ça veut dire que ces
bombes est en réalité c'est possible
excès puis
bâti l'industrie partout partout et de
l'homme il ya de la marine comme on
s'épie le g et on sait se sait peut-être
peut-être que l'exemple qui prient dans
ce bal à dos le yi extrême mais le
centre appartient un goût qui jamais le
québec aux états-unis crefo le cache là
dessus que tous ses employés paypoz
parce que parce qu'ils ont en commun un
mode j'aurais on a une quête spirituelle
mais tu fais quand même travaillé du
monde sans les payer mais ton
pis ils y arrivent des temps forts d'un
mois même si comme à quiconque osera par
un peu l'accident qui ont eu à cause que
ça fait mal paraître le centre c'est ça
existe partout ce genre d'assaut si
comme dit à dire c'est la personne
problème et non la mort
du fait qu'il faut aussi deux cas pas de
départager les deux c'est exact ça je
pensais aussi un mouvement de beaucoup
défendre ces substances locke parce que
justement on est tellement dans
l'extrême que c'est pas bon c'est légal
fait des cadets qu'intriguer considérait
pas bon on est toujours poussé à
l'idéaliser par le crâne au maximum
avant de le ramener au milieu d'un beau
juste que je veux dire que du bon train
oui je sais que du bon c'est juste je
pense faut faire attention à ce que
règles expérimenté des enfants mais faut
faire attention avant de s'auto
médicaments très discret henry ce qui
peut les mener avec ce lobby il en tire
des brestois où toutes les drogues tous
les médicaments qui sont sur le marché
il parle quand même un processus quand
même rigoureux d'études puis de suivi
pour voir les effets secondaires
possibles ce versus on met chaque humain
en
tout cas personnellement je dis pas que
c'est mauvais je suis une autre
alternative que tu peux peut-être
essayer de comprendre ce que c'est comme
si l'oeil au juste les médicaments juste
mais ça soulage dit le coach fait savoir
que l'autre option existe peut-être
qu'on vient pas tant pis toi grèce avec
les médicaments si le vote si le moche
devient légal qui devient utilisé en
thérapie ça va devenir par définition un
médicament au oui mais plus naturelle
presque ont ratifié comme un bar
alternatif de kits veut peut-être faire
des séances de mach assisté une fois par
mois durant trois mois je tenais prêt
comprend des médicaments tous les jours
pour de s'assumer comme hésité à jeter
dessus de là dessus c'était comme
associé à la contre culture hippie
faisait comme à l'automne touche pas à
se les est une honte est stoppée mais
genre
c'est la cause la gare il y avait
tellement de
monde à
la barre puis ça le
concept en train d'arrêter la gare puis
ça fait un gros souffle et c'est là
qu'ils ont tout arrêté seulement ça a
été fait très politique mois si mettons
ont fait d'être liriano des études là
dessus qu'il en est des déchets des murs
ou des neuro psychiatre qui étudie ce
qu'ils font et et font des études qui
est usé que les patients à voir les
effets de ce pigeon si ça marche s'était
montré que ça marche monsieur
mais mon poing dans le fond mais
j'espère pour klose espion c'est juste
que je trouve que
des menaces et
je trouve que on donne un peu trop de
crédit à
écouter
pharmaceutique romain dumas et parce que
je trouve quand même la plupart d'entre
eux s'est décidée shortcut
puis puis je comprends que des cas
extrêmes 100% de bind il y en a qui ont
vraiment besoin de médicaments je trouve
quand même qui on évite en espèces mais
le papier pour dehors c'est juste
qualité aux autres ce test je pense par
la défense d'un défenderesse des fins je
peux te les fans tout ce qui est des
rails compagnie compagnie mais autres le
côté médical aussi moi ça m'a permis de
trouver des trucs d'enfin grande mois
que j'aurais jamais trouvé tout juste de
l'expérimenté avec des amis puis
socialement d'être avec des gens de
confiance
moi ça m'a permis de me questionner de
découvrir des choses sur ma personnalité
que j'aurais jamais découvertes ou que
je me serais jamais permis de vivre ou
deux c'est que ça vient faire des
petites ouvertures que je sais pas quoi
puis quand tu reviens à tout et puis à
part des fermes il faut que tu vives
avec cette nouvelle ouverture le triple
je dis pas tout le monde à aller faire
de la drogue mais il est juste rien je
suis un court d'idées la farce et ça
passe de prendre de quoi pour paul vella
exactement ils pas capables de sortie
ski à hauteur de lui parce qu'ils aident
spin ce procès en dit à la société aussi
tout pour l'ambiance tout le temps tout
le temps là dessus mais on est toujours
stressé pts et issad ça devient
difficile de replonger dans toi moi même
puis en exil comme des petits trucs qui
tout ce club
c'est pas juste un homme noir glacé pour
te soigner ou pas de soigner souci pour
vivre des expériences
je suis permettent de voir des petits
traits ce type de vote différents
manques afin de voir le monde d'une
façon différente de mon sérieux en
exergue chose ou du moins de voir les
choses sous une autre exact parce qu'on
abat vous pensez qu'on est libre mais la
lave et les airs et
la vie à chaque jour tu penses que tu
fais des choix que tu lui fais police et
en fonction de tout ce qui tout ce qui
viennent soit le petit toit l'appui tu
fais ce chemin entre que je me mettais
absolument perspective la main puis ça
fait pas que je me révolte la société ou
con quand je replonge dans ma vie je
suis bien content de refaire ce que je
fais suivre les normes peut être comme
on doit à être mais ça me permet qu'un
futur avec moi avec mes amis de me rends
compte que baisse et ceux qui se livrent
à s'arrêter puisqu'il ses 40 ans
attendent d'être toi juste parce que ça
parce qu'il faut que je respecte a
raison faut respecter les gens ou
tottenham et oui les gens qui vont si
elle a été créée exact
mais c est actuellement man qui sévit en
groupe si c'est quelque chose qui à être
humain fait depuis
six mois puis puis ce que tu dis le prix
par rapport à
sortir un peu du monde pour être capable
de le revoir d'un autre angle au spo à
l'université j'avais fait un travail sur
jean leloup puis j'avais échangé une
coupe de courriers avec lui pour avoir
sa vision du voyage même temps puis le
parallèle que tu fais je veux le faire
avec le voyage pour qui c'est exactement
la même chose lui ce qui me disait c'est
que la raison pour laquelle ils
voyageaient s'était pas nécessairement
pour voir les autres cultures mais
c'était pour sortir de la vision de la
société qu'on avait pour ensuite revenir
dans sa vie puis le voir sous un autre
nom tellement c'est exactement la même
chose j'ai l'impression quand tu tues tu
sors un peu puis survient dès le
lendemain le lendemain d'un trip de
drogue sorte tu fais comme acquis et non
le hier quelque chose que j'avais pas vu
juste en gloria existe dans ma vie que
maintenant je le vois tu
voyages puis la drogue je pense à fait
comme un genre de titres dans le thé
dans la boîte lui aurait dit ça mais
sans savoir plus perdre de vue un peu
plus
un mot est sorti moi t'aimer ton voyage
nicaragua paraître en tout et un coup
danie j'étais allé
avec mon ex et hockey récréatif c'était
vraiment ce genre de voyage l'été
je l'aï pas qu on sait pas où est ce
qu'on va dormir demain on le bouc au fur
et à mesure on fait on voit tullow qui
glorifie
les sentiments des libertés que genre de
voyage le procureur c'est que t'es
jamais quelque chose que je sais quelque
chose avait jamais vécu ça s'explique
aussi que met-on tutu vit quand tu es
jeune parce que quand tu es un enfant
c'est juste comme georges pas ce que tu
veux mais harman et c'est comme ça ça
n'existe plus
pile de pouvoir toucher à ce club si tu
reviens plutôt comme un nouveau regard
sur ta vie parce que c'est qui ma vie
que je pense qui comme
impulse été ou sont malgré moi ou ce
litige juste comme qui fit l'iif au
châssis full faso dans le fond c'est
comme construit puis on peut vivre
exacte d'une manière où s'est construit
pourquoi ici
puis prendre le sait qu'un convoyage
c'est juste dans ton dans un livre choc
et l autre rencontre et maintenant tu te
rends compte quelqu'un soit en replay
c'est comme par hasard dans un after
tentant bain pour ce soir et que
d'autres cette foule des liens qu une
personne que tu reverras jamais dans ta
vie puis tu racontais des impacts qu'ils
m'a raconté à personne tant ce soir le
c'est comme ça ça donne elle-même a pas
d'autres supports puis
le lendemain et ragondet aux personnes
c'est comme sucrés les expériences se
rend compte qu'ils tissent des liens du
monde vraiment rapidement tu prends le
temps de regarder autour de toi genre
crise existants et maladie tarbes le
jean kaki et pas au québec piqué gens
découvrent et des coquins et
puis après ça aurait ainsi pu être comme
moi à chaque fois comme acquis lui c'est
un feeling le savez c'est un genre de
vision le du monde que tout d'être
attentif aux jeunes attentifs aux choses
à ton environnement garde ceux qui à
chaque fois de plus je le garde pendant
dix bonnes minutes ça fait déjà ses
cartes marche quand est-ce que tu
t'arrêtes tu fais quel arbre incroyable
de thé à montréal
tu as tous les arbres et
des bons meilleurs l'impression pour est
gardé sa mindset levin au moment présent
magic j'écoutais s'être cassé moment
donné je n'avais pas cette équipe il
disait voir quelque chose que j'ai tout
le temps maintenant souvent le postillon
ville rise of assets merci la vie même
des personnes qui le verbalisent
pleurait mais parce que j'avais entendu
pas de caisse qui disait la meilleure
façon de te rendre compte que tu fais
quelque chose c'est de te le dire pour
demander à force de te le dire tout le
site et j'ai comprenez vous c'est comme
une boucle tu invites te le dis tu dis
tu le sais plus trop juste et c'est bien
normal le tout le temps d'une habitude
et c'est comme ça honnêtement dans ma
vie de ma vie est vraiment la vie la
plus banale l'impression de vivre le rab
100% du town qui combattit je vis je
m'assois reste de mes amis je me dis
rennes je te reste les admirons fils
drive je mange je
mets 10 as tu envie drive mais si ces
raisons c'est autant le fun de passer du
temps avec toi pc ctif genre justement
c'est normal mais ne veulent pas non
plus mais là on a regardé autour c'est
comme en ville
la chance de fêter la guérite mes amis
la veille j'ai des amis j'ai la chance
de pouvoir me déplacer jusqu'au
restaurant devoir me payer de la poutine
avec mes amis qui sont un mauvais renvoi
de fox et le christ de reuil veux que je
te dise de plus maintenant les gens te
regardent en face à gasquet c'est vrai
mais je serai des tantines king et el
jadida le maître mais ouais je travaille
là dessus même si c'est rohff parce
qu'on mange quelqu'un qui veut tout le
temps s'améliore et qui a cassé d'abord
tout le temps quelque chose de mieux à
est
là dessus non c'est pas bon non c'est
bon basket jo non michel ait comme toi
je veux vraiment être plus présent dans
le monde non mais c'est bon parce qu'en
même temps il ya plein de choses que
tout à fait que moi j'ai jamais fait pas
ce qu'il veut que je vis beaucoup dans
le moment présent je les passe pas
vraiment me limite cambrin j'ai jamais
fait de deuil j'ai jamais ce qu'on
graphique et en ligne aussi d'essayer de
trouver
j'accepte humblement président wade tout
comme pas vraiment non plus drive va
essayer d'aller chercher à les fatiguer
j'aime ryan blanc
exact
tantôt au dessus ou au quotidien
francis les deux arrêts battant semaine
dans trois ans puis janvier quand même
en com mais si je pense que c'est idiot
mais
aussi vouloir atteindre quelque chose ça
ça demande un travail seulement factice
la balance de la balance
mais c'est peut-être connaître le site
off mais c'est pareil mais tu as raison
de l'état de voyage en fait jamais la
fête avec découverte chose de tout
nouveau ça traîne andré malet top et ça
fait vraiment du bien ce que moi ça me
booste witcher j'apprécie tout content
de revenir au pid de vous envoie en paix
bon c'était ben oui c'est ça c'est ça ça
fait ma job
comme plus d'énergie qu'ils étaient huit
source 5 rue jules vivre notre vie notre
vie oui pire accident mais ma faim on
sera plus quand des scandales impliquant
le par un très beau en vient on est
content si la vie mais j'ai réalisé ce
dans dernières années ça passe vite un
tabarnak parce qu'ils mettront à rester
dans la même affaire parce que quand tu
sors mes tempes tu voyages trois mois ça
fait vraiment
un chapitre rapport dans ton histoire on
le sait le 3 modes sur une force et une
partie mais si tu reste immobile non
vraiment il pendant trois ans dans la
même place le même appart le même ça
passe parce qu'ils ne forment pas de
souvenir fort oui c'était pas ça chapeau
de l'histoire si jamais l'on fait c'est
juste c'est un long fleuve continue puis
dans ta vie qu'un mettons gens je pense
beaucoup à eux seuls ces jours-ci quand
je me projette mettons sur mon lit de
mort puis j'essaie de ça me permet de
relativiser des marbres qui m'arrive en
disant un jour ça va juste être un
souvenir mathon ce moment là cette
période le messie pendant quatre ans
c'est la même apathie fait la même job
tu te lèves eure ou même
les week-ends ce fait les mêmes choses
quand sur son lit morts ce quatre ans le
va être un souvenir versus les trois
mois qui viennent passer le son un
souvenir aussi égale sûr que tous ces
trois mois puis l'autre c4
ça va être la même
année je me rappelle à amener je te
rends star club puis je faisais le job
ça va être ça ton souvenir mais des fois
ce feeling le même il frappait quand
reviennent voyage ce matin les besoins
d'avoir vécu un million d'affamés en fin
de compte et puis tout le monde était
exactement moins qu'avant qui
grandit fo à 1000 pile tarifs que c'est
la même nouvelle c'est que c'est pas
assez visiblement n'ont rien à raconter
c'est
fait pour expirer
à saint-élie gens et on ne
sait quoi les chances que toi tu es
vivant
souvent les yeux matin en battant le
stress
il dit on se lève désarme pas qu'est
ce que c'est pas la mer mais on a
tellement une belle opportunité de vivre
tellement leur appui en et demain
d'ailleurs c'est pour ça que j'ai eu
vent que j'avais fait un instagram c'est
pour ça qu'ils aient que je voyage puis
c'est pour ça qu'on en parle encore
aujourd'hui si je pense c'est qu'on veut
le monde fasse on veut que le monde
sorte donné oui le monde va être plus
beau monde si mon voyage je découvre
plus pis hrovatin patent être moins
individualiste le sait c'est que ça va
changer critique at il faut d'autres
dotations de idriss et comme tu es tu
comprends plus l'autre l'entité plus
d'empathie des plus souvent à l'avant
centre au centre et souhaite aller plus
ouverts depuis la première fois qu'on
s'est rencontrés ouais je trouve que tu
es vraiment je trouve que j'avais
l'impression d'avoir fois je suis à
vendre et que tu avais date ait puis
disposer de ce qu'on s'est rencontrés je
te raconter la fois que j'ai fait de la
six mois m
assises avait pas de samaké ouvert à
apprendre comprendre du plan n'a pas
envie de changer télévision sur
certaines choses je trouve que derrière
ce que je suis juste ce pôle je te
connais pas assez mais je trouve que je
n'ai personne que tu veux découvrir tout
plein de chips de là à vouloir évoluer
prendre un genre de chemin de fer une
telle que je me trompe mais je me trompe
oui mais ce que tu dis c'est vrai mais
je sais pas à quel point j'ai eu un
shift dans les dernières heures c'est
une façon peut-être que toi de
t'exprimer qui différencie lui il reçoit
d'une autre façon
non mais des fois parce que je comprends
ce que joe veut des 26 caméras
c'est moi j'ai vraiment de la misère à
m'exprimer dans la vie gagne phonique je
comprends ce que joe veut dire que tu
avais la plus fermée mais je pense que
tu ne l'a jamais été c'est juste que la
façon que maintenant tu te présentes
tola plus ouvert mais je veux toujours
été mais tu le démontrer - alors là
c'est pas un petit qui c'est la façon tu
te présentes au monde mais le talent là
d'une personne plus souffert toujours
été mais c'est comment tu te présentes
j'ai tout le temps été quelqu'un de
relativement ça fait six ans que je suis
moi je te dis que relativement timide
puis comme souvent c'est
pour le plus
embêté n'est pas la personne la plus
comme avant de rencontrer je prends dans
mes bras world 6 mai
métier j'ai tout le temps des quelqu'un
de curieux de temps que tu es quelqu'un
qui voulait apprendre tant qu'équipe
quelqu'un qui voulait voyager je voulais
mais j'ai tout le temps été aussi tu es
quand on parlait la dualité team et on
voit qu'ils achetaient qu'acheter
mettons cégep le téléthon c'est
secondaire il s'agit je voulais je les
ai vraiment voyager tout jeter copie
j'avais fait une coupe des petits
voyages continuent à faire dans
l'entente mais je voulais de choses je
voulais voyager fait remonter des
enfants à voir le monde puis je voulais
faire la musique dans la vie du
pilote harvey ou serait pas mise et
pilot j'ai fait si je fais ça dans la
vie
titov a tendance à la ville par ville
par la musique
moi je travaille en crise pis si je pars
petite auto russe alfa puis si malade
puis je m'étais aussi sur 100 m non mais
tout lui réussi à passer trois mois
moi j'ai comme didier qui joue à mettre
ça de côté je met ce que je vois c'est
que firent les rails
puis je me suis tu as dit
aman et je veux travailler pour ce jeu
trahi je travaillais pour être le
meilleur musicien que je peux arrêter de
gamme avec ce que ça va finir par
m'amener à l'eau puis je joins l'utile
agréable puis je vais voyager dans la
musique météo tout ravagé tout en fait
des voyages les bref
c'est peut-être qui sait ce que je
t'aime trop focus ou si ce genre les
enfants à faire ce qui fait que parce
que justement quand je pars en voyage
tellement j'ai l'impression que 15
mallet toute cette pression l'aude comme
faut que je travaille fort il faut que
le genre tout anticrise tout en tout cas
pour que ça marche
j'ai l'impression d'être tellement
a tellement belle tellement
le jeu adéquat du genre d'équipement
brown en personne
oui parce que j'ai tellement comme le ya
rien gpo l'espèce des leds gotham pas
mal à s'arrêter c'est pas les fenêtres
petite voix qui dit fuck effet pour
litres avec sursis pas ceux qui laissent
tout de ramener personne ne comprend pas
il faut qu'on ait différentes
personnalités en fonction de l'espèce
l'impie onu redd tightly maniement du
main event et sa notice c'est au feutre
setup jury mais c'est même plutôt rock
l'autre quand tu passes justes qui ont
été conditionnés je pensais bien plutôt
à voir leurs différentes personnalités
en fonction des différents métiers
vivent ça vient quand même avec son lot
de ces se
construit de jarret faut payer son loyer
non
[Musique]
pourquoi
c'est ça qu'ils disent la famille comme
les groupes il est embauché comme
astérix q67 ça pour ça je passe très
bien et c'est pourquoi c'est un ou
l'autre ça devient ça vient d'où ce ca
ou l'autre si toi ou tu vis dans
des situations vraiment
difficile qui est peut-être que lyon
peut au choix par la job qui aime pour
puis on peut souhaiter c'est quand même
je pense
c'est un héritage aussi un nom mais
quand même à raison c'est ce que celle
de l'an passé leur faut vraiment
apprécié ce qu'on dit non mais tu peux y
est même steve jobs tempo moi je fais
des choses que j'aime pas des fois aussi
tout comme moi mais j'essaie dé faire en
respectant qui suit logistique chanceuse
plateforme pour le tout vécu nous loach
iliad était sonné
et des inégalités qui n'ont pas de sens
mais les rames du ballon je fais ta foi
que j'aime pas mais j'essaie de le faire
en respectant parle étant moi même
si toutes lettres que dans mon cas c'est
juste la différence en dés fois rentré à
maison à maison puis je vois ma blonde
pilot j'y prenne à faire dans pas être
parce qu il qui me stresse pas ce qui
s'en vient et puis si tu es
versus en voyage que j'ai comme il ya
des dépôts solides mais faute pose la
question
est maintenant 1500 serait plus correct
d'avoir un petit appart à 500 erreur
rendu là c'est foutu tu écoute toi
vraiment aussi têtu travaille dessus
depuis que tu as et charles parce qu'il
faut avoir ce charlot tu le veux
vraiment avec ce tu le veux vraiment ne
devrait pas déranger de travail
je comprends ce que tu dis puis l'autre
affaire c'est quand tu rentres chez vous
puis le dessus quand même jugé par
figure à partir d'un mot non plus mais
quand tu rentres chez vous you rien
quitte en parler je dois est exactement
comme paix en voyage plus de paramètres
exerçant tapas des appartements tepa
compare cela aux actes donc si mais
c'est non mais
s'améliorer cette offre ouais bah oui
dans la séance ans et ça c'est certain
ces soldes reste que c'est faisable dans
le fond
c'est d'arriver chez vous puis de jeu
c'est d'ailleurs là j'arrive chez nous
ma blonde et le pire comme qu'est ce que
je suis rien que je peux faire sur six
enfants avec le stress dans ma vie fait
que les sites ont deux côtés depuis
l'âge de 18 ans je me le dis à moins que
moi si je travaillais au quotidien
société bah oui mais c'est ce que
j'essaie de faire mais c'était de faire
parfaitement déjà mais comme
être un peu plus
un peu moins agréable que se stresser
pour l'information votre table ait envie
nos émotions c'est juste pas être ou
l'autre c'est d'essayer de trouver un
petit peu inquiet c'est comme si l'on
parle qu'on a l'impression que quand on
vend voyage ont déconné qu'on devient
une autre personne puis qu'on revient
dans notre vie mais on devient une aux
personnes qui ont peut-être décidé de
mixer les deux lois et miss et puis
j'avais pas dire depuis très cible de
plus de franchie depuis avoir des pnp de
plus devoir faire des affaires qui nous
tente pas la vie se formant des enfants
qui n'en peut mais juste pas ou l'autre
et y
avoir à choisir
j'espère c'est qu'on a une grosse
affaire qui se connecte au milieu
mais c'est ça mais c'est au fond c'est
de ramener ce que tu es ce que tu
apprends sur toi tu en ce sens le puy de
désintégrer à ta vie
ah parce que au final le quotidien si la
majorité des journées exercent à
temps que
continuer à faire de la méditation 20
minutes par jour à tous les jours quand
les menteurs mais quand tu réussis de
l'oeuf à
six semaines de plus pour le tout donne
juste un exemple pleine affaire qu'on
peut conquérir un voyage que tu as le
goût de ramener ça fait tellement du
bien d d d d d insérer dans ta vie tu
parles de voyage quand on est champion
de voyager moins 20 c dans mes premiers
voyages
et il voyage c'est une des façons mais
tu
t'apprêtes eu des expériences et c'est
aussi le côté des films font vivre des
affaires qui t'amène à quelques pas qui
tu étais jamais allé c'est apprendre
quelque chose que tu te connaissais pas
que la musique tout ceci ainsi des
expériences qui nous risque différent
surtout à tous mais l'emplacement raison
qu'est ce que tout le monde comme sidiki
capables de se payer un voyage puis
c'est vrai que le monde est un chanceux
de vivre s'est offert le top sur ma
raison mais chaud c'est pour tout le
monde que le temps quand c'est le cas
tant
qu'on est chanceux et oui
faut peu importe peu importe la
situation cesser d'essayer
exact
c'est impossible de genre essayer de
comme changer de tête à faire pour
essayer d'améliorer
combien exactement
j'avais pour voyager puis je travaille
sur mon appareil mises est limité
le monde s'il faut qu'on recommence à
s'entourer des bonnes personnes je
trouve que beaucoup
j'aime intérieur goumain un battant et
je commence à me rends compte qu'il ya
beaucoup de gens qui sont mal entouré
dans la vie puis qui pense que peut-être
cse est entouré puisse avoir des amis
puis ses soeurs mais c'est juste c'est
postaux si vous êtes mal entouré puy
foot permet de bien choisir son
entourage du bien choisir tes amis parce
que ça va te faire évoluer ça va te
faire changer puis je trouve qu'il ya
pas beaucoup de gens qui se permettent
de changer d amitié ou de
yachts of commons pas tout le monde qui
ont les mêmes outils c'est pas tout le
monde qui ont la même les mêmes
intelligence et ses réussites cet os oui
mais tu es pendant six mois avant vous
le jetez pas la même personne je serai
jamais que je suis si j'avais pas mes
amis jury le toucan brantus date fait
c'est quoi j'essaie fait on sait si j'en
ai entendu parler vous savez c'est roger
moore dans la partie car en soi bien
perdu 100 pour ça
mais on a pris des décisions à un moment
donné j'ai rencontré que je suppose que
les diplômes va jouer de la musique
oui peut-être qu'on se donne c'est
peut-être juste ouvert
soit le plus servi à sem nettoie le plus
possible des j'ai l'impression que si
les gamins genre de c comme un genre de
mots qui se passe si je verrai si je
vais partir d'un petit peu plus loin
c'est quelque chose qu'il faut
savoir parce que mettons des amitiés on
a des amitiés puis qui dure depuis
longtemps ces documents et on est un bon
exemple de ces nous autres on est amis
depuis qu'on a depuis qu'on est en 5e
année
cette amitié leurs pendants relativement
longtemps
a été
concentrée sur un même
sens vraiment changé notre relation
d'amitié pas vraiment changé jamais puis
moi j'ai cette expérience et avec plein
d'amis mais allez évoluer
pas vraiment si c'est ça la fait pas
vraiment et puis
puis après ça mais ton
il ya des relations qui reste immuable
dans le temps qui évolue jamais qui
reste cette relation d'amitié lol et les
genres d'aminatou de ses amis lorsque tu
te revoilà mais plus tu parle de trucs
de la vie hippie t ta job c'est quoi
ouais tu étais à ta maison de bésicles
être le plus bel ex étaient amis quand
même sauf que cette relation là jamais
été challenge est jamais été brisées pl
après ce mets ton tu rencontres des gens
comme toujours au dessus puis maintenant
moi je t'ai rencontré toit par cendres
et dieu sait que votre relation un outil
à trèbes cendres et qu'elle ait été
syrie dans toute l'école de ceux
d'essence à l'été garrocher dans le gras
le moins cher
mais pfff c'est la même chose contre la
fabrique aussi puis mettez vos relations
ont été gâchées de toutes les colis et
de courrier mon mode ont été modifiées
dans le temps ont évolué et puis
moi je vois ça maintenant je vois ce
joueur qui cette relation les volumes le
check in check d'enfants et prennent des
relations qui ont jamais évolué parce
qu'ils ont jamais challenge et ce truc
là c'est un autre dogme on a vécu quand
même
un bruit clou dans notre relation
j'imagine que tu voulais pas si
longtemps que ça puis j'ai même sur
notre relation a évolué depuis ce moment
là le titre que ce soit puis
positivement vérité
puisque je pense qu'il faut tu t'en
rendes compte il faut que tu te rends
compte qu'il est entouré de plein de
monde que j'ai une miss ses relations le
sait les mêmes qui était leur intense a
peu évolué ça va changer ayons pas la
dynamique est restée la même fait que ça
nous permet pas une grandir parce que la
relation comme telles a pas grandis tu
fais que je pense que deux le sport
c'est le motif de dire ipad oui ça se
peut ça se peut de chou de choc et des
relations d'années sans un autre niveau
puis de dans le sang au niveau de
changer la dynamique puis
ça pas besoin d'être complètement cessé
chaleur
mais juste derrière est conscient de
faire et il est dans le fond mon
entourage et mon entourage auguste
entourage lui sans dire qu'on est
complaisant et détruire pas vraiment
modifier pas
grandir collective exact quand je
reviens à la maison maintenant j'ai tu
pas appris quelque chose demain soir
rigide su travailler sur moi j'ai tout
juste passer un bon moment où tout le
long je me dois la soirée votre finir je
te passe à autre chose je pense d'un
petit j'écoutais pas nécessairement ce
que les gens me disent ces projets non
plus d'ailleurs je pensais tu as quand
ça va être trop assez tôt pour que je
puisse marcher c'est exact si c'est ce
tontine king quant à l'essor et d'amis
changements soient jamais grandir peu
importe quoi ta relation si tu es tu as
droit dans des frictions que tes amis de
pas être d'accord mais si tu fais juste
penser à autre chose quand et avec eux
tous le droit de changer ce que vous
avez évolué puisque vous pensez
peut-être que pour l'institut tu le vois
pas le méchant persuadé avec tout ce que
vous avez vécu toit en sortant du haut
des toits vous autres travaillant ici en
sommes à tous les jours
je pense pas vraiment c'est notre
relation professionnelle définitivement
mais d'amitié je pense vraiment avez
vous eu le temps d'évoluer plus votre
relation
c'est plus une relation kasma de famille
qui doit cesser non seulement je
comprends ça pour ça je sais ton frère
et
vous
n'auriez
pas rater ça évolue pas si mauvais je
pensais pas du tout
mais
avez-vous le goût de voyages stéphanie
jarre de soutien un peu de sortir de ce
que vous faites normalement petites
dalles et voyelles pas faire un trip
ensemble
parce que c'est dit c'est la meilleure
mais oui
la fois que la foi qu'on a bandé l'autre
jour c'était une situation qui nous
sortaient de notre quotidien examen
facture allemand que ça
pour les dissimuler ce fauve qu'il
faudrait mais plus souvent parlement
faire des espèces des situations
justement
c'est de plus vulnérables ou s'il est
vous
qu'at-il vulnérables s'abat en est que
les gens mangent et pas vulnérable avant
dans ma vie pékin
on retrouve à quelqu'un est-ce que vous
parlez beaucoup m'ont déposé ma demande
est forte de votre stress des affaires
personnelles que j'ai parlé plus des
choses qui me sont arrivées de
ça crée des liens il a aussi laissé sa
bande de jeu que je fais de l'argent
qu'il soit besoin de me dire pour que je
comprenne
mais tu as raison que c'est plus une
relation de famille que demain ouais ses
inconditionnels sais c'est
qu'aujourd'hui plus belle relation sa
part ça c'est une magnifique shannon
avec les
gens nus ou six ans mike bryan 6 j pal
plus on se parle pas tout mais la
première fois en prison max brod la
police mais brad pitt depuis l'âge de
quatorze 14 ans qu'on que c'était mon
meilleur ami piloté ce qu'on a on a pris
10 faire un chemin mais je sais que d'un
match dans marne ou que lui d'amande ou
que je suis a besoin de quelqu'un un
dernier répit c'est un conte sa patrie
se fout c'est une des têtes bien entouré
le signe des choses qui permet vraiment
de toi même te défoncer les portes de
parce que techno malewa tu vois
quelqu'un ouais c'est ça je le répète
souvent aussi moi je dis souvent je
serai pas qui je suis 100 sûr parce que
je sais que peu importe ce qui m'arrive
de me ton jeu pages et plus de job j'ai
pu d'argent j'ai pu dès jeudi j'ai déjà
ça pousse tellement est il plus facile
des 3b de prendre des risques discipline
à faire parce que tu vois toujours est
entouré c'est comme fait la chose la
plus importante c'est de cette franchise
et s'ils ne la changerait avec magie
n'est pas épanouie si ch'est tout seul
sait déjà qu'ils sont pas bien entouré
j'ai juste envie d amener dans mon mot à
dire et l on vote entourés de basket tu
peux pas été pas nourrir les commandes y
fait tout est un risque tout le temps
c'est un autre genre de richesse qui qui
vous encore plus en france à vos plus
que tenait bien entouré moi je pense que
henry qui vaut plus que ce puits de
travail des races les gens avaient passé
leur relation ils donnent pas assez
d'amour passée c'est comme une fleur
c'est quétaine mais c'est ça c'est la
fois la plus importante n'ayant rien
d'autre on est des humains on les fait
pour vivre communauté en relation on
parle à des gens on n'est pas des
ermites le pire les relations les
négligés comme
à l'opposé ça fait pas de sens de dire
que c'est sûr on a besoin ne s'est pas
de ce concours un barde le plus jeune
moi j'ai travaillé ces scènes depuis mon
notre force centrale à sion je pense la
relation en fait que je travaille plus
dessus c'est
tellement gros clash pitié aujourd'hui
je suis tellement heureux qu'on a dit
gay puis qu'on a travaillé là-dessus pis
ces deux époques comblement de vision
qu'ont les deux personnes comme un petit
quand je parle de ma bisexualité quand
je parle de ma musique de fans l'adorent
lui
0 savistes tellement ce répit puis je
trouve que tu as raison en fait on ne
sait pas on a de la misère parce que
souvent les gens ont peu savent pas
comment aborder leur amicalement bien
d'en parler si fort que ça va amener sa
superbe salle arrête de quoi ma réalité
faut juste se fasse que tu le fasses si
vraiment
le goût de faire ça que quelqu'un de
vivre
parce que malgré que sa tente de faire
vivre à d'autres mondes vont faire rien
d'autre à faire vivre à d'autres membres
certes des tours une personne puis à la
santé membre obligé avant aider
quelqu'un d'autre c'est juste à l'infini
exemple
vous avez tout à fait un très beau que
j'ai remis ça dans excusez moi je la
mets des guillemets car quand un diplôme
et un premier tube de saccades elixer ce
qui arrive it's like comme ça arrive
souvent sur la md mais fini nos voix à
celles de la rocinha mont-bleu tard
garde n'importait qui les petits gars
gel c'est tellement un bon feeling
le
cas
si quelque chose qu'il ait piqué mais y
exercent est philippe bailly fun board
hommes d'antoine
est un hôte humain je t'aime tu es bon
on n'est pas capable dans la vie de
farce où on est gêné ou souvent
c'est peut-être que c'est juste comme
dans la dent comment on est élevé dans
le monde a grandi c'est pas des réflexes
qu'on a mais si ces réflexes la rive
tant que les examens parce qu'il y en a
ici on s'est fait mettre quelque chose
en avant ouais tout juste de
jean vient et un autre à faire un pas de
casque dans le podcast ça disait il
enfin que je disais tantôt bastion du
drive by en reste et de détecteurs une
passe et gentil leur quelqu'un dit la
rue quoi tu l'as dit pas
comment ça c'est l'autre personne là
régis est content pilote ça se peut qu'à
se met à faire c'est le site c était
dans un bon jour d'hui tu l'as pas ces
délits constituaient de le penser tu le
fais tu payes ton chandail est beau
c'est con mais c'est ça et j'aime
comment tu viens d'articuler cette
phrase le trou s'est tu viens de le
penser dit lui aussi je le fais
tellement voyage touche par là que tout
le monde que je donne des recettes de
donner tellement d'amour mais je le fais
moins folle ça je le fais moins s'ils
s'appuient
juges travaillent là dessus cette
personne ne sait pas il ya peut-être là
fabien c'est tellement des petits trucs
riddick est
là c'est peut-être le vrai père ça si la
pire journée mais qu'ils je vais vous
dire quelque chose gibbs est terrible
c'est terrible c'est si la chose a pris
conne qu'il vient d'y penser tu aime
rappeler ça puis j'ai réalisé à quel
point c'est la chose la plus stupide
juste avec ce que je suis j'ai une belle
aux deux fois à fait arrivé dans mon
choix je me suis dit crise et dans un
but commun est habillé gip a dit j'étais
trop jeune sinon
c'est trop jeune et sa région c'est
positif we are est alors est bien pris
sauce allait mieux lancer sur le pied de
guerre depuis positives et la soirée
qu'il trouve déjà mais elle a
réalisé que la chose a
réagi mme banon mais au moins quand même
à
la prochaine fashion show que tu vas
dire
exilés tabac sodano
était ce parce que mettons ce genre de
ce genre de réflexe le ce n'est pas la
première mais vie que j'avais se l'était
fait que toutes les fois basculer ces
années de l'amour ou est ce que je le
retenais jeudi soir leurs câbles
qu'ils ont l'habitude le frapru
benoît consciemment
vient donner de la motion même source
mais oui tellement important
je trouve que en fait c'est son
autodéfense dit à l'amour et à une
personne mais chris pine n'avons tu peux
la voir l'amour et c'est l'amour a fait
c'est pas juste ce que ta femme
il ya différents niveaux d'amour mais
tous - 5
km
seront vraiment la montre dames en basic
ces critiques ça me fait mal au ventre
l'amour mois ces dames en jeu c'est là
que ça se passe c'est comme douce que
celle ci dessous
moi je passais mes temps qu'un jeu c'est
pour moi qu'un chedjou avoir quelqu'un
pich compte c'est ça c'est la blanche
jusqu'aux mixte et ben oui c'est
tellement une raison ouais moi je m'en
venais six textes et
sa musique il envoya j'avais mal au
ventre j'avais mal aux 20 m ennuyer je
sais que c'est de la moustiquaire
toutes ses aises
ces succès
panama dont nous met sur braise faut
c'est comme un
c ce qjelt il a la patate à pont royal a
mais
facile j'essaie de le congeler le matin
je le sens je regarde ma femme jusqu'à
pastique jeunes j'essaie de comprendre
ses coaches pas capable dans sa section
s'explique pas ces genres plus grand que
nous allons
ce genre la chaîne ne s'est jamais
plaint bohème on peut écrire des mots
qui qui démolit tout a expliqué la mode
comme sort
exact j'étais là bas
parce qu'elle porte c'est possible et
émettant justement l'amour de
kibo
ligne les papillons de ce saint type
d'amour mettrie gpo les papillons chaque
fois que je vois ma blonde serge
confolens très beau mais je laime en
tabarnak chargé l'amour ça transforme ce
message pas qu'une soirée les papilles
en reviennent bah oui vous allez faire
une sortie à va mettre une robe
toutefois capoté ou jean rameau titre
comprend le salaire perçu ce que j'aime
ici c'est pareil
supplétifs à pied on va revenir pour
penser à autre chose
c'est loin les métiers de coups de fil
aux célèbres
femmes chez les grecs comme trois types
dans mon oreille comme l'amour eroski
comme l'amour plus charnel justement
plus l'amour passionnel
piteuse ton amour
nikolic google goog.o dalmat d'un amour
qui est vraiment comme l'espèce d'amour
supérieur qui est vraiment à la
bienveillance pileux
le partagerai longe en maternelle un peu
parce que j'ai mis sur
matt cutts ici
le point positif il ya différentes
l'amour que j'ai pour pme qui joue mais
selon les grès les grecs qui a l'amour
et ross qui est l'amour passionné of the
body l'amour filial qui est affection
affectueux friendly love the last orgue
et inconditionnelle famille bastien
quand elle m'a tellement
à gap et qui est sifflé ce universal
love
loup douce qui est playfull
forte chute la
brague ma came ted langue lasting love
puis file aux tiers qui est sauf love
absolument que je trouve vraiment être
vraiment la bardonnie dit le comité de
comités de langues la stime alors ça
s'appelle traque mois kipré allemand
pragmatique et la décision tombera dès
comme committe avec quelqu'un c'est
l'amour mais oui je vois ni de mettre
mes efforts mis d'énergie avec cette
personne là
qu'il
s'est passé ça parce que mettons un
amour charnel qui est je me rappelle
plus c'est quoi le type en amour mais
ton friendly flirter schultz pitot
l'amour pragmatique hommes de développer
quelque chose à long terme et c'est deux
choses de ces aspects que taipei le
flirt échoue cela avec dont prague man
loves la fin tu peux avoir cet amour
dans ta vie
si m
toutes les infos sur une même
personne
cgt à gap il s'offrit une relève comment
tu décris se fait juste d'aimer son
prochain
comme cela tu piges thèmes comme
l'amour la ressource et messi comme la
môme est ici mais tout comme quand on
vend voyage puis on voit des petits
monsieur madame des cochonneries se
mordent la rue petit livre pas ils font
pitié me tuera leur achète tout leur
panier parce qu'ils font petits c'est un
genre de selfoss anniversaire jean
marie l'armée a pas j'adore c'est le
métier suite à ce message
je connais pas et personne ne tombera
c'est comme un genre c'est une version
je te connais pas je pratique y mais
j'ai une amour qui me donne envie de thé
dépit de tous ces parfaits n'a jamais
terminé tu peux retourner chez vous en
avant en acheter ton panier j'ai
l'impression aux cycles universe sur
love
ça revient un peu ce qu'on disait avec
avec à dire que lui voir maintenant le
québec
sa famille fait qu'il ya eu deux tiers
on en parlait beaucoup mettons le du
vaccin un duo ensemble le pin de jusqu'à
1 mais tout le monde ça fait que passer
division l'intéresser vraiment ces tas
décisions majeures acceptant ce que
tu peux voir pas être en accord sauf que
c'est vrai que ça adoucit le clivage
tout le monde on vous ne pourrez pas
ressentir de l'amour pour une personne
qui pense différemment de moi ne font qu
on mélange les deux ans je sais pas
pourquoi tu penses pas comme je pense je
ne t'aime pas what the fuck c'est quoi
c'est un king je pense je pense à je
t'aime pareil tu es une personne c'est
une belle personne juste monde d'accord
sur ce sujet de mes tournées sont
souvent on ne l'a pas pu - et puis moi
et tout mes amis c'est rare qu'on pense
pareil je trouve ça le fun qui est exact
petit peu avoir l'opinion delaunay oui
mais tu peux
tu peux vraiment l'apprécier peuple en
fait pour n'en garder un petit
pourcentage pourrait juste à améliorer
ta vision soir la tienne on
mélange la montre
c'est bon les grecs y avait comme un
vent on parce que là on se posait la
question mais probablement cessé
aristote s'était déjà posé ces questions
là sous main
c'est bizarre en fait parce que non les
grecs dans le fond ça par rapport
à ce que l'église sera pas un peu ce que
l'amour est réel machrouh avec le avec
le passé pitt s'est
formée alors non non les grecs star va
ce soir l'as rome antique s'est vraiment
avant mais ça a été est-ce que non à
fond ça je n'ai pas de quoi est ce que
je vais demander à mesure de la religion
c'est quoi les grossistes et il ya
plusieurs divinités divinité
alors dieu des dieux de tout prévu sauf
que j'aime ça me sentirai c'était plus
de ce type je pense pas que tu aies la
religion sikh avec comme un peu l'espèce
de pouvoirs divins de sacrées de d2 qui
était comme la le la ligne la ligne de
pensée tout c'était plus les philosophes
moi je m'en sers james
bond
voici l'histoire voici ce que
l'allemagne a besoin d'eux ils les
venger le
jésus mais ce qu'elle a dit non mais si
j'enlève ma fille aime ton prochain
pour
dire à briguer doivent brûler nos
voyages au nicaragua les gens sont
vraiment catholique c'est beaucoup puis
mais je connais pas la religion vraiment
beaucoup mais j'avais vraiment
l'impression de voir une différence de
la boa ici aussi le dit c'est new kids
et manison cette affaire l'appui de ces
comme jeudi la société comme tu
viendrais ce qui est écrit c'est de
l'amour et de la mort de leurs proches
ton prochain céline l'option encore une
fois pas tout ce qu'ils lisent moins
joyeux demande servi à masquer
mais aussi d'habitants
je la regarde qu'elle fait encore et
adversités dans le fond sur l'étude pour
le pot de fin qui l'a fait nous y
compris les dents lancé l'ancien
testament qui est comme un peu le texte
qui tels des jeux avant tekki combats
près la même base de judaïsme et signe
après ce n'est plus une révolution puis
c'est un nouveau testament qui histoire
de jésus tu mets dans les testaments
quand même sa facture plus de gens
étaient vraiment induit des kanaks et
vous aimez entre hommes ont détruit en
direct
c'est l'être humain était tellement cela
mais aussi des passages que c'est c'est
la plus belle poésie me diras pas décidé
qu est ce qu on pense qu'on laisse ou si
ses problèmes et ses affaires je ne veux
pas décider que je te crois message
texte comment tu c'est souvent seul
problème est que plus décidé de choisir
un tombereau oui mais pas la vérité
alors raison car tu prends juste les
passages qui te convient
si je pense que encore aujourd'hui je
reprends les passages qui nous convient
parce que sinon qu'est gensac applique
ce dû littéralement dans x factor sauf
qu il y aussi les plus avancés fax is it
c'est justement le toit de jésus c'est
vraiment aime ton prochain ces genres
tendre l'autre joue gagner
mais c'est la mandate mais c'est après
ce qu'est ce qu'on
est en principe que j'applique gagne
j'ai appris je vous apprendrai principe
aujourd'hui
la majorité des gens partent avec une
bonne intention nathan fake depuis que
je me dis c'est souvent moi je suis
moins vexé parce que je suis hyper
susceptible d'en vie plus juste moins
même si quelqu'un fait quelque chose qui
te déplaît la majorité des gens toujours
des bonnes attentions fait comment
discuter de même si tu es fâché après ta
blonde embêtant parce qu'elle affecte
quelque chose qui te fait pas plaisir
uttam a reçu son message elle avait pas
de mauvaise intention les gens ont
souvent une bonne attention si rock les
gens sont méchants fondamentale souffrir
d'insécurité
il y en a déjà mais ça méchamment c'est
vraiment rare le bord souvent du prêt si
c'est une bonne entrée 8 c'est juste un
rebond bien plus facile de vivre quand
dessus 4 dit quelqu'un qui te couper
d'un fils
ce pas ce qui te poses vue plus ces
genres il voulait couper
mon attention c'est d'arriver le plus
tôt passé chez porsche époque woippy toi
t'as pas mal réagi ségolène
rigole
ça ça n'est un gilet vraiment vraiment
les salines mais non aujourd'hui tu sais
comme kaka je te caches d'achat puis
quelqu'un me couper les cheveux
tellement que ça va changer c'est elle
même si une femme il est mal je
comprends pas pourquoi j'avais jusque
là c'est cela mon passé que dix
personnes qui passent chez exact ça
changeait quoi et gsm edge et pas eu le
méga jusque là la femme encore mouche
klaxons puis maintenant béton jean pépin
lumière rouge lui elle me retombe vers
la personne avant toi popo le genre ça
m'a pris longtemps
enfin genre un petit
jeu si j'avais l'option de la place à
part les claques sont complets un genre
de
halo
3 plus
tard j'espère que sénégal journée
cya parce que je t'en prends vite
d'amendé papillon
ça va nous amener là je suis persuadé
qu'en six hommes john lipsky torrent a
passé dans le monde - je trouve que
c'est tout pour un clavier ya de quoi
être vraiment meilleur c'est même lac
van damme la stieger regarder tout le
rassemblement que ça fait toutes les
places comme ça pendant le mal qu'on
prend comme ça dégage pour guérir toutes
parts des fonds qu'ils mal je sais pas
pourquoi faut que ce soit demain mais
tout part d'un mal que je trouve ça
magique qu'on écoute en train de
tranquillement avec syco 1,8 million de
personnes
de changer la vie tout le monde puis de
marquer tout le monde sur sow
la personne est a de la misère à manger
demain puis là il faut que la fatigue
c'est capoter ce qu'est ce qui est du
monde vit mais faut tellement rêver hein
on s'en va ce
rapport à l'avenir parce que c'est
facile de
checker l'actualité puisse dire ça votre
tombe mal puisque prennent enfin et pour
ma petite affaire horrible qui se passe
dans le monde mais mettons son compare
avec france n'importe quel autre époque
de l'humanité je pense quand même qu'on
s'entretue
tic ont convenu ensemble qu'il ya moins
de violence qui est plus de personnes -
deux mondes qui meurent de faim de la
violence mais il ya plus de monde mais
s'il ya plus de rennes
fait que j'ai comme l'impression que les
moustiques et on sent vous dit on est
quand même encore dans inspire à
l'échelle de la planète et lui manque
encore des enfants qui apprennent
comment oui comment vict l'impression
qu'on faisait du club exempt
tranquillement on sent pas que le
pouvoir de terminer la race humaine se
régulant par son gang la maturité pic
éventuellement c'est comme il dit glad
la méchanceté la guerre de la violence
livre d'abord de mon amour
je trouve qu'on apprend tranquilles ceux
ci c'est long mais on apprend nos
expériences je trouve que l'idée des
chutes qui arrive si je trouve que je
suis pour toutes avec la radio non non
non non non non benjamin prince mais je
ne sais pas non d'enfants je faisais
juste moche je trouve que je trouve que
c'est d'école sans ce qui se passe dans
le monde en ce moment ces émeutes ont
honnêtement
tendance à penser qu on était déjà au
delà de tout mais peut-être que le
changement va jamais à la vitesse qu'ils
ont voulu le canadien mais je ne sais
pas moi je suis moins optimiste que vous
je pense par rapport aux sages
il va
le monde va rester comme il est le web
non mais si ça mais sensiblement un ton
métier je pense et aux jo qui est
partagé une story disant qu'il y avait
une simulation qui avait été fait dans
les années 80 où est ce que la fin du
monde arrive en 2040 le premier vrai
gros bouleversements la voie reliant
2020 le
décor
pour ça je
suis d'accord moi je pensais que le truc
comme l'ukraine tout en
arrivant je pensais pas vivre ça je
pensais qu'on était derrière nous fait
que ces gens là ont
contrôlé la nature c'est pas humain de
match le temps mais en même temps je
comprends que cette berline crétier
comparativement à deuxième guerre
mondiale s'est pas c'est pas un nombre
comparativement croisade
mais je pense que non seulement
l'optimisme j'avais oublié un facteur
qui lé réchauffement climatique
comment ces métiers les bouleversements
savent à
qui
ça va créer
des
jeux s'est protégé même
si c'est drôle parce que je me dis que
si ça va vraiment pas bien maintenant
que la planète conduite de sujets les
pressions de theix et ce qui va
peut-être prendre que tout le monde va
servir ça irait sur une arrogance et se
laisse et c'est maintenant la seule
affaire que je vois que mon vieux villa
sera pas que je vois comme étant
la solution me tombe sur ce que je
m'accroche quand j'ai une limite
d'anxiété par rapport à l'éco anxiété
ces choses là la seule affaire sur
laquelle je m'accroche je me dis
faut que autant l'être humain a réussi à
nous amener le autant faut que je fasse
confiance que l'être humain que la
technologie aps la science fille les
serveurs vont être capables de nous en
sortir parce que sinon sinon je vous
dirai pas s'il faut que tu pars du
principe qu'un agent des bonnes
intentions
les intentions si des intentions
monétaire le si à un moment donné sauver
l'humanité ça devient dangereux
ça va le devenir éventuellement mais
j'ai l'impression que le il va il ya
tellement d'argent sur la planète
présente voyais lendemain ce qui
tendrait qu'il ya donné quoi 6 billions
tout d'abord anglais je suis persuadé
que les bilans
jal c'est en nettement si vraiment je
trouve à eux de vrais mensonges ou
à merci
dans l'avion c'est du temps de voter me
just
say party
j'adore merci à
aa2 du contenu excellent tu as tout un
pataquès combien
oui
si vous voulez plus de contenu excellent
comme ce que vous venez d'entendre aller
sur le titre le pitch vous abonner pour
trop de l'or parmi six autres au delà
ouais trois pièces par morlaàs par mois
et vous avez les pas de carte en avance
acquise avec les premiers de votre
groupe d'amis avoir quitté les podcasts
qu'ils allaient avoir pouvoir avoir une
avance quand vous allez tuer le la
dynamique entre les amis de tout le
temps avec une avance sur les jobs en
avance
le toit mais avec pétillante une avance
sur l'humanité complète en plus en plus
parce que lâcher le podcast su ni voulu
nous entendre josé davantage on fait des
encore moins de filtres après chaque pas
de casque avec là on vient de finir de
tourner le podcast on va en jaser on va
être pile et nicole non nicole il est
maintenant évident comme un fils
travaille à plat ce détail est là mais
on jase on parle de conversion qu'on
m'aide à voir mais ce si vous voulez
avoir accès
mais heureusement pour nous
malheureusement pour vous s'est excusé
sur têtu il faut s'abonner abonnez vous